so the next big trend at the moment is
that celebrities are jumping all over
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo because they
don't have enough of your money they
want more and the studios don't want to
fork it over to them so they want you to
fund all their projects so the the big
ones people know about is Zach Braff is
getting the sequel to garden state made
via Kickstarter and he got the money he
but he got it like add a second
basically in about half a second through
one tweet uh Veronica Mars is coming
back and it's going to be crowd funded
and then the new one now is James Franco
wants 500,000 bucks to get a couple
books that he wrote made into movies and
this seems very bizarre to me because
these people have more money than all of
us and they also want to still take our
money we also pay a lot of money to go
to their movies and all that stuff it's
like the height of just Hollywood bull
[ __ ] show absolutely I guess it worse
but I feel like when when the whole
concept of Kickstarter came about it was
such a great idea and it was cool for
these indie artists who needed some way
to make their crappy album so now right
you know and and good ones too and
actually logo had its first ever
crowd-sourced television series called
DTLA the air that was all crowd source
and it didn't logo wasn't a part of it
until till later but I thought that was
interesting so it was crowdsource and
then made its way to the network right I
think it's kind of with a way it should
be is that it starts out with a bunch of
people who don't have a ton of money
they put something together then someone
takes notice like a small TV channel and
puts on your project but already being
famous if you already have over five
hundred thousand dollars you shouldn't
ask poor people to submit to your
passion project I mean does this just
like the 500,000 also from James Franco
seems bonkers because I'm sure the guy
has millions of dollars so like we're
all out there putting our stuff out
there and working hard so why should he
have people that have less money than
him fund his project like what's the
psychological thing going mixed feelings
on first of all part of it does say to
me he probably does have five hundred
thousand dollars that if you really
believed in his own project
you can invest in himself the way all of
us have invested in ourselves in with
whatever money in time we have you know
like normal people building themselves
up you're like if I have ten dollars
that's going to go towards my career my
internet whatever it is that we're doing
but you know I'm not entirely mad at it
I know when zach braff did his people
were rolling their eyes and annoyed but
a lot of people really liked garden
state and studios if you've ever work
with a studio before they're really
impossible they're not going to give you
final caught your vision isn't going to
come to fruition they're going to say
you know well we need like a bigger star
or a better soundtrack we want to change
what you've written into this this and
that so I will say the argument for some
of these celebrities is that they
already have work with the studios and
probably haven't gotten even show who
they really are you know to them to a
James Franco or is that crap or thinking
well I've got to put out all the stuff
but it's been under you know all these
people in suits telling me this is who I
am in front of people so a Kickstarter
IndieGoGo gives them the opportunity to
be like okay I'm an artist that people
already are familiar with but here's how
I would do it if I were allowed to you
gave me your money this would be my
vision rather than the corporate vision
we probably see most the time right and
as artists you're speaking my language
so why don't we listen to the artist
himself James Franco tell us a little
bit about what you're doing to all help
me adapt these stories we just need a
little bit more help I'm just asking you
for a little more help I'm putting money
into these projects because I believe in
them I believe in these filmmakers and
these stories are very important to me
and very personal I find that this
process is very exciting but this is an
the best way to make movies because in
this way the movies we want to make get
made in the ways that we want to make
them that the only considerations are
how to make the best movies possible
yeah and his goals are so not be aren't
they do shade I just it's kind of
douchey though yeah and also I think it
does go to what you're saying of like
when these things started it was like
let's get water to children in Africa or
you know let's have helped cleft palates
or something like that Kickstarter that
were just like that to you that were
like we want to make a cool movie but
Studios won't listen to us cuz they're
the man so fund my movie about I mean
they're Garden State esque movie that
just had nothing to do the celebrity or
is a crap there was a lot of that yeah
i'm gonna start us that need auto-tune
i'm almost there i just need auto-tune
there's a lot of that i mean remember
what was that Jenny Owens young or
whatever she couldn't make her second
albums or first didn't do as well I
think that it was her so she funded you
know her next album on that so people
funded their own projects that have had
semi Fame I just don't think it was do
this Zack crap Franco thing that it's
become like a thing so on a personal
level would you guys cuz I have thought
about it I kinda I just generally don't
like the idea of asking for people I
like putting stuff out and hopefully
finding like ancillary ways that you
make a dime off it but I can't say that
the thought has never crossed my mind to
be like look I do some good stuff that
people seem to enjoy and if everyone
that watched or listened or read my
tweets would give me a buck a month I'd
have a lot of money and I could probably
do this in into 10 times greater way but
somehow that even feels a little slimy
to me does that feel like like that
you're asking when it's like I thought
about that too i've actually it'sit's
I've had projects where I thought I
could put this on IndieGoGo or a
Kickstarter and then something about it
made me feel strange asking for money so
maybe we need therapy for that because
clearly
no problem going saying I'm amazing pay
me for it right great idea uh Jan and I
are going to start a Kickstarter for
comedians that need therapy to be able
to accept Kickstarter money also I have
an idea i'm gonna start a Kickstarter to
stop rich people from doing
Kickstarter's Sean any final thoughts on
it I I don't know I one Kickstarter
thing I think is really funny as I saw
parents or potential parents put a
Kickstarter up to adopt a child and I'm
thinking if that's their starting with
the adoption process and they're gonna
have a Kickstarter for school clothes
are gonna have a Kickstarter for college
yeah they were saying we need help to
adopt a child and lay and as I that is
there in for a rude awakening I think
they think that being parents really
inexpensive like if you already don't
have the resources that's a little scary
to me yeah funded no I hope that I think
their aunts and uncles are like okay
I'll do this once but this is it kid
yeah service is just like they end up
getting like a hundred fifty bucks in a
guy exam or something okay